time perhaps is most precious when time
is running out
Angela McLaughlin hasn't seen her girls
face to face since lockdown this was the
day they could return to the hospice
whether mom is terminally ill with
cancer the one thing being found me I
just want to live oh it's gonna be okay
things are gonna be all right you may
remember Angela we filmed with her
during lockdown when communication was
by technology easing restrictions brings
them closer there were no big hugs not
yet
Angela's immune system is compromised
but this was timed together after a
difficult time apart
I messed up on Mother's Day and must my
mom's birthday and just be an Amy's
birthday and just basically getting to
cuddle maybe I think it's hard to know
that she'll be okay because I can't be
there and
just not being able to be there for my
mom and vice-versa
because I really really would sorry it's
not obviously at home but it's like okay
now we're better O'Malley actually
against you
Scott's emerged on day one of phase one
to socialize of songs negotiating nine
weeks apart has been a challenge one
they know all too well in the hospice
setting we all feel that their absence
of the people that we love that we can't
see but here where time is so clearly
precious it's all the more acute because
being ready to spend some quality time
alone and that's what we need an end of
the day our family as a treatment yeah
it's about small steps and simple
pleasure it's been more taming the
ghettos hawks and then just get out and
about
yep that's some quality thing spend some
money
Oh James Matthews Sky News